cet invité aujourd'hui c'est vous
laurent joly bonjour bonjour merci
d'être merci d'être sur ce plateau vous
êtes historien spécialiste de l'histoire
de l'extrême droite et du régime de
vichy directeur de recherche au cnrs et
vous signez la rafle du vel d'hiv quitte
ici qui vient de sortir chez grasset et
qui vous a demandé je crois plusieurs
années de travail aidé enquête nous
sommes les 16 et 17 juillet 1942 l'un
des événements les plus tragiques
survenus en france pendant l'occupation
écrivez-vous l'arrestation en deux jours
par les autorités françaises
collaborationniste de 12 1884 hommes
femmes et enfants juifs en plein paris
arrestation qui sera suivi de leur
déportation dans les camps de la mort ce
que jacques chirac qualifiera dire et
parable en 1995 un épisode dont les
détails sont encore 80 ans plus tard
assez méconnu il vous fallait faire ce
travail
le détail du côté des victimes étaient
connues on sait ya eu énormément de
témoignages on sait comment les victimes
ont ressenti ça on s'est également bien
sûr qu est-ce qui avait précédé les
accords policiers entre vichy et
l'occupant l'occupant faisant une
exigence et vichy acceptant d'y répondre
et entrant dans un engrenage criminel ce
qu'on connaissait moins et ce qui est
finalement le coeur de cette histoire
c'est que c'est une opération de police
donc c'est avant tout comme une
opération de police que je les ai étudié
avec sa préparation les filles jeu
comment on a organisé concrètement le la
sélection des victimes et puis le
déroulé de ces villes de ces de ces deux
journées une journée et demie du point
de vue des policiers et de leurs marges
manoeuvres ce qu'on se rend compte qu'il
avait des marges de manoeuvre et que ça
a eu un effet sur les résultats qui ont
varié d'un lieu à l'autre d'un
arrondissement à l'autre d'une commune
de banlieue à l'autre on va y revenir
dans un instant peut-être pour ceux qui
ne sont pas familiers de cette histoire
on va rappeler le contexte de cette
rafle ou plutôt de ces rafles elles ont
lieu donc le contexte est celui d'un
riche et un régime de vichy
collaborationniste au pouvoir depuis
1940 convaincu en 42 que l'allemagne
yves a gagné la guerre est enclin donc
vous le disiez à répondre aux demandes
faites par part par les nazis puis le
régime de vichy joue en fait à ce moment
là sa dernière carte peut pratiquement
parce que pierre laval est revenu au
pouvoir perd la balle c'était l'homme de
la collaboration en 1940 il dit elle est
tellement loin que le maréchal pétain
l'avait renvoyé et donc il est revenu en
avril 42 avec une feuille de route qui
était très clair il faut collaborer il
faut donner le maximum de gages aux
allemands les allemands à cette époque
là ils veulent des travailleurs en
allemagne pour les usines qui travaille
pour l'effort de guerre donc quand en
plus ils vont demander des juifs pour
les embryons de ses eaux pour pierre
laval c'est évident qu'il faut leur
livrer le maximum de juifs des étrangers
des apatrides c'est pour vichy des
personnes indésirables il faut s'en
débarrasser ça fait deux ans que vichy
les met dans des camps en zone libre par
exemple donc l'engrenage de la
collaboration il était quasi inévitable
et il s'est hissé enclenchée alors la
demande est allemande mais le donneur
d'ordres lui bien français c'est rené
bousquet le chef de la de la police et
dans les jours qui précèdent la rafle
vous le disiez tout à l'heure va se
mettre en place et vous le décrivez avec
beaucoup de documents une minutie
bureaucratique autour notamment du
fichier juif oui alors le c'était pas du
tout évident en effet que le vichy la
france de vichy accepte de livrer des
juifs à paris parce qu'à paris on est en
zone occupée mais on se disait ça va pas
être forcément évident la population et
pas forcément très antisémite puis
s'agit là maintenant d'arrêter des
femmes et des enfants on avait déjà
arrêté en 41 des hommes mais c'était
pour les internes et sur place tard il
s'agit des déportés donc on dit ça va
pas être si évident que ça et donc on
confie sa la police municipale or la
police municipale à les effectifs mais
c'est pas elle qui a le fichier le
fichier c'est un service service juif et
donc on va lui demander de sélectionner
les gens et donc ils vont prendre les
juifs apatrides de plus de 16 ans pour
les hommes et les femmes 55 ans limite
d'âge pour les femmes 60 ans pour les
hommes ils ont 27 me dévoiler où l'on
voit les filles qui sortent 27 mille
quatre cents filles dansent des
objectifs assez élevés il pense que ces
gens qui sont les plus fragiles 1 cc
pour la saison des juifs polonais
pauvres on se dit qu'on va pouvoir on
arrêtait 22000 à peu près dans dix ans
ils ont des objectifs élevés et après il
va y avoir la pratique et de la la on
voit qu'ils ont moissonné le plus large
possible ils n'ont pas tenu compte des
exemptions qui seront plus tenir qu'ils
auraient pu le prendre en compte on voit
qu'il ya des infirmes on voit qu'il ya
des des gens qui ont fait la guerre dont
qui aurait dû être protégé puis on voit
surtout quand on regarde les fiches qui
dia les trois quarts des enfants sont
français les gens des enfants français
donc il n'aurait pas dû être arrêté
voilà donc on a un objectif de chiffre
qui est très élevé et puis le résultat
ça va être qu'on va en trouver que 9000
sur les vingt-sept mille 400 fiches
d'envoyer un taux d'échec et des deux
tiers et on a quatre mille enfants plus
et c'est là on va rentrer dans cet
engrenage où pour gonfler les chiffres
pour faire en sorte que le bilan qu'on
présente idéalement soit pas si ridicule
que ça on va insister pour que les
enfants partent tout de suite avec leurs
parents on va y revenir dans un instant
il faut rappeler qu'il n'ya aucun
officier allemand qui procèdent les 16
et 17 juillet aux arrestations lui parce
que bousquet qui est chef de la police
française qui est un pur produit de
technocratie française lui considère que
c'est l'honneur de son administration
qu'il n'y ait pas d'opération mixte
voyez pas de soldats allemands est
policier français comme c'était le cas
en quarante et un ensemble sur le
terrain dont il tenait vraiment ce que
ce soit la police française
traditionnelle qui opère ici 12,7 sur
cette singularité parce qu'on voit pas
ça ailleurs en europe des policiers des
agents de la paix afin de garder un
aspect qui vont arrêter des juifs au
petit matin et doute la question que
vous posez parmi les questions vous
présidence leafs et essai voilà à quatre
mille cinq cents policiers mobilisés
comment ont-ils pu alors comment ont-ils
pu ce qu'on voit c'est que en fait tout
le coeur de mon travail ça a été de
rentrer vraiment dans leur tête en fait
leur mentalité les marges de manoeuvre
dont ils pouvaient dont ils pouvaient
faire faire preuve et on voit qu'ils ont
des marges man et on voit qu'en fait la
plupart ont fait leur travail mais sans
elle et qu'en fait il y en a un qui le
dit dans le livre
on pouvait on pouvait pas ne pas arrêter
d'hui vous pouvez faire de notre mieux
on pouvait pas ne pas arrêter du fait en
fait on a l'impression qu'ils se sont un
peu entendu entre eux pour en arrêter
quelques-uns voilà une fois qu'on a
arrêté de trois familles après on fait
plus de zèle on peut présenter à ses
chefs de trois familles dont il y en a
assez peu finalement qu'on fait du zèle
mais ça a suffi pour en arrêter en
arrêté 9 millions voit qu'il ya quand
même un taux d'échec des deux tiers donc
c'est ça le paradoxe c'est qu'il ya pas
une opération en europe de l'ouest qui
est équivalente arrêté treize mille
personnes jour ça c'est vu nulle part
ailleurs et en même temps c'est
considéré comme un semi échec par les
autorités la plupart de ces juifs
arrêtés donc et ont été emmenés au
vélodrome d'hiver un tiers des personnes
qui ont été arrêtés ont été emmenés
directement à drancy le vélodrome
d'hiver n'existe plus aujourd'hui
c'était un stade couvert dans le 15e
arrondissement
l'histoire est connue ils ont passé
plusieurs jours dans des conditions
dantesques avant d'être déportés via des
camps de transit seule une petite
centaine des personnes arrêtées ont
survécu et donc vous le vouliez à
l'instant et vous passer un long moment
dans livres à en parler contrairement à
certaines thèses a encore défendu
aujourd'hui par l'extrême droite
française c'est la théorie dite du
moindre mal vichy n'aura jamais autant
livré de juifs français aux nazis que
lors de la rafle du vel d'hiv parce que
pendant parmi les treize mille arrêté il
y a quatre mille enfants et la plupart
d'entre eux sont français lui si on veut
rentrer dans le don ce jeu qui
d'ailleurs assez ignoble de dire les
français auraient été puissent préserver
que les étrangers comme si livré des
enfants étrangers
c'était moins grave que livrer des
enfants français donc cet argument est
ignoble mais en plus il est faux parce
que cette fameuse théorie du moindre mal
ou vichy aurait protégé les juifs
français pour et en sacrifiant les juifs
étrangers jamais vichy n'a livré plus de
juifs français qu'en juillet 42 à paris
le 16 et 17 juillet trois mille enfants
français même à bordeaux en 44 même
quand l'ami 10 ordonnera des
arrestations enfin le sécrétaire général
au maintien de l'ordre darnand ordonnera
des arrestations de juifs français on en
arrête ramoin vous voyez cette théorie
ne tient pas il suffit soit 100 de
regarder les chiffres on a en quelques
semaines nous livrer 25 mille 25 mille
juifs et après la machine va s'arrêter
parce qu'il va y avoir il va y avoir une
émotion dans la population gens vont
être choqués et vichy va être bien
obligés de ralentir donc vichy été en
mesure de ralentir ce qui fait pas
allaiter 42 où il veut vraiment livré le
maximum c'est la politique de bousquet
bousquet a dit aux allemands je vous
donnerai le nombre de juifs étrangers
que vous voulez c'est bien ce qui se
passe à l'été 42 mois des enfants
d'ailleurs et c'est page assez difficile
à lire qui seront séparés de leurs
parents là encore
du jamais vu si j'ose dire et qui sont
déportés ensuite poursuit avec des
inconnus absolument là aussi on a on a à
faire et c'est vrai qu'en travaillant
sur ce livre j'ai vraiment pris la
mesure de ses singularités parce que je
me suis mais après tout est ce qu on a
fait pareil ailleurs est ce qu'il ya eu
des cas où déjà c'est thierry de
déporter des gens mais en plus les
séparait des mères séparées de leurs
enfants fassent y avait quelque chose
d'extrêmement cruel d'autant plus que
les enfants étaient libérables c'est
dire que déjà on les a séparés cet été
très très dur mais les enfants auraient
pu tout à fait ne pas être déportés
vichy avait tous les moyens de le faire
dans bus qu'ils étaient français ils ne
le font pas ils ne le font pas parce
qu'ils sont pris dans l'engrenage
criminels et que pierre laval veut faire
croire à l'opinion publique qu'en fait
les parents ils sont en train de
construire des baraques en pologne puis
les enfants ils viendront une fois que
les baraques seront prêtes qui pouvait
croire sa personne et les gens qui
venaient voir pierre laval notamment
leurs représentants des églises
protestantes qui est venu le voir qu'ils
étaient choqués mais vous comprenez pas
que les gens vont mourir et pierre laval
faisait semble pas comprendre il écrit
dans son journal le pasteur bonheur je
lui parlais massa qu'il me réponde et
jardinage
vous lisiez à l'instant contrairement à
ce à quoi s'attendait le gouvernement
ces arrestations que les officiers
français vous voulez organiser
relativement discrètement ont suscité
l'émoi à paris la consternation lui
évidemment la théorie on sort des fiches
on va aller au petit matin chercher des
gens mais en pratique c'est pas ça en
pratique il ya eu ça a été tout de suite
dramatique les gens pleuraient les
voisins sortait sur le palier donc c'est
aussi une raison pour laquelle on n'a
pas arrêté autant de gens c'est que
c'était c'était chaque arrestation
prenait du temps était lente des femmes
qui qui qui jeté des chaises qui ce qui
se débattait donc çà çà çà a été
publique la rafle du vel d'hiv est
éminemment public c'est d'ailleurs
terrible de voir fait qu'il n'ya qu'une
seule photo celle que l'on voit là n'a
pas de photos de cette de cette rave qui
a été pourtant quelque chose que tout le
monde a vu en tout cas dans les
quartiers de l'est parisien où il y
avait beaucoup de juillet dans le 11ème
dans le quatrième dans le 20e d'ailleurs
il sort de cette photo est intéressante
c'est une photo de propagande mais elle
a été interdite de diffusion suisses et
les allemands 41 avait fait de la
propagande autour des premières rafles
il s'était dit on va faire la même chose
mais ils ont tout de suite compris dès
le 17 juillet dès le lendemain ils ont
compris que le plus la population ne
pourrait pas adhérer à une propagande on
voit qui est cette photo que c'est une
photo qui est conservé dans les archives
de la bibliothèque historique de la
ville de paris c'est une photo qui vient
du journal paris-soir paris midi il y
avait de l'autre côté une légende
antisémite on voit qu'un tampon allemand
via un refus et les allemands ont donné
l'ordre à la presse parisienne qui
étaient complètement soumise qui étaient
aux ordres deux allemands de ne pas dire
un mot de la raf qui s'était produite
l'avait donc voilà une opération que
tout le monde a vu mais le lendemain
dans le journal pas un mot il aura fallu
attendre
1995 laurent joly plus de 50 ans pour
que le rôle de l'état français de la
police soit reconnue de cette opération
qui s'appelait terriblement d'ailleurs
vent printanier c'était les mots de
jacques chirac lui a reconnu les deux
s'étaient déjà il y avait déjà des
travaux d'historiens qui en parlait il y
avait déjà eu des des prises de parole
comme maire de paris jacques chirac
avait déjà fait quelques jours 1986 mais
l'aco plus haut niveau de l'état y est
un homme politique
enfin le président d'art public qui
reconnaît sa responsabilité de l'état
français dans est aussi une certaine
manière de la france parce que ce sont
des agents ordinaire de l'état vichy au
même moment à livrer aussi des réfugiés
de zone libre donc il y avait besoin
d'une parole forte qui reconnaissent la
gravité de ce qui s'était passé petite
parenthèse vent printanier je le dis
mais c'est vraiment noyé dans le livre
c'est un mythe parce que tout le monde
parle de vent printanier et en fait ça
s'appelait pas comme ça voilà faut le
savoir mais famille faisant il y avait
plein de d'idées reçues sur sur la rafle
sur la rafle du vel d'hiv autant pour
moi d'ailleurs on dit la rafle du vel
d'hiv et vous raconter qu'il y à il y
aura d'autres rafle dans l'été des
rafles après la rafle 1 au bout du
compte sur plusieurs mois un adulte sur
deux visés par le l'objectif initial a
été exterminée exactement vous avez tout
à fait raison de rappeler parce que on
va dire que les deux tiers ont échappé
au monde arabe donc que c'est un taux
d'échec important mais en vérité la
rafle a continué on a continué à traquer
ces gens qui étaient souvent polonais
qui parlaient mal le français et au bout
du compte on en a trouvé 4 milles en
plus des neuf mille adultes qui avaient
été arrêtés les 16 et 17 juillet et donc
il y aura des commémorations pour les 80
ans de la rafle du vel d'hiv bien sûr le
16 juillet prochain dont vous ferez
partie vous signez notamment un film je
crois pour france télévisions on vous
retrouvera dans le film que signes à
stéphanie trouillard pour france24 merci
beaucoup monsieur laurent joly être venu
nous présenter ce livre la rafle du vel
d'hiv donc il vient de sortir chez
grasset à l'occasion des 80 ans de cet
événement tragique merci encore c'est
beaucoup